you folks are awesome have I mentioned
that lately okay so this was a video I
had not planned to make but I stopped by
my my peel box today and there were a
whole bunch of packages that I just
didn't expect to get and I have never
done an unboxing before well I I sort of
have I've like I've sort of shown off
stuff that's gone to the PIO box before
like on that was that was a patreon
video one of the few ones that I did
that was that was patreon exclusive but
this because like I I wanted to share
with everybody and I've never done the
thing of like opening up when I don't
already know what's in it
and recording that on camera so we're
gonna do that and before I do actually
start to do that first I'm gonna take
note of something that I was sent
actually last month that I'm still
really stoked about so from a subscriber
I was sent jammie Dodgers which I
haven't opened yet I've been kind of
saving because like these kinds of
treats I sort of do more around like
Christmas proper and obviously I'm
recording this a little bit earlier than
us going out but yeah I am I am looking
forward to these because you know taking
a fair amount of British TV shows and
entertainment and movies I am I was
aware of them but I've never had them so
looking forward to that
that same subscriber also sent me a DVD
that I haven't had the chance to check
out yet because it's a region 2 and I
don't have a means of playing that yet I
died I can probably figure it out but
I'm actually not the most technically
proficient person in the world so I'm
working on that but in any case taking a
look to other stuff so despite the box
that I don't order from 1-800 pet
so let's see what we actually got here
whoo scary hey I just finished in Britt
I just finished watching you're
embracing my Hogwarts house a Slytherin
story video and you said you needed a
Slytherin scarf so here you go I also
included hat because why not
I bought two pairs of hats and scarfs
but I never had another Slytherin to
gift them to they they've never been
used and sell the tags keep up the great
videos and I hope you enjoy your gifts
Ashe PS I apologize for the pet meds box
it was the only box I had big enough for
the scarf and hat oh my goodness oh oh
okay this goes on immediately that that
feels good love that and I'm not gonna
switch the hag because I want to keep
this one going oh that's awesome Thank
You ash so next one is an odd shape it's
very okay didn't wreck anything oh okay
long letter I might cut that down the
reading of it we'll see but I'm gonna
here we go dear Nathaniel I really hope
this reaches you in one piece and with
some luck I'll be able to send a lot
more in the future
as fellow online critic and Doctor Who
reviewer text only so don't worry oh
good he's not competition I really
appreciate your opinion and inside sadly
I'm not in a position to contribute to
your patreon account that's okay but I
do have some merchandise and memorabilia
I'll gladly send whenever possible after
the countless hours of enjoyable content
you've contributed it felt right to at
least pay you back in some way anyway
basically this is just to say thank you
and keep up the great work because
you're truly appreciated if possible it
would be great to know you receive this
so I'll know if it's okay to send you
more
well I did receive it it is okay this is
from Rick oh wow okay oh oh these are
cool okay so these are these are art
prints basically so we've got got Rose
Tyler the style on this one
we've got the 11th doctor man Amy Pond I
really like and I always have a special
tattoo and we've also got Amy Pond by
herself and I do really like these sorts
of things that are you know really
realistic you can Ritz really you know
you can tell who the real person is but
I always find the sweetness when
somebody can find a way to apply a very
distinct artistic style to these kinds
of characters as well oh these are
gorgeous okay well these are immediately
going in the portfolio where I keep my
my prints and my Commission's and stuff
so I can figure out what to do with them
I've got so much stuff I need to get
framed it's it's like it's not even
funny at this point alright so this next
one probably not really specifically a a
Christmas package we'll see but I know
who it's from and I know what it's going
to be like in the broadest terms because
this is coming from Talon Middleton now
if you are a podcast listener I would
very strongly recommend that you check
out the relatively deep podcast network
that M Middleton and their father Alan
who's probably where this is coming from
run
they talked primarily comic books but
they they also cover a lot of other
stuff and and cool things and I him he
Alan specifically has the quarter been
where he reviews comics he got out of
quarter boxes and I sent him a whole
bunch of stuff from a quarter been
including some very very ninety stuff so
what have we got here ooh okay we've got
pop culture clash Alan Moore's tomorrow
stories we detested and despised the
first American and u.s. agent by the
whoa interest oh and more Jack be quick
so we got Alan more stuff which is all
even at his most high on himself Alan
Moore is always interesting and his
tastes are always interesting enjoy this
anthology title well thank you and this
card would lead me to believe this might
in fact be Christmas to say well it's
Christmas colors at least let's see may
all the joys of the seasons be yours
happy holiday have a joyous 2019
Professor Alan and Emma that's awesome
and what's the other thing we got more
tomorrow stories yeah so it's three is
it the first now it's the first four it
is the first four issues of tomorrow
stories which which is an anthology
collection
so I'm guessing Alan Moore's name is on
it but a lot of individual writers here
so I'm guessing he may be curated it but
I do love in theology books like I'm
actually kind of a sucker for heavy
metal I've been picked it up in a while
but I I do like anthology titles so bad
Thank You Alan that was awesome all
right what else we got ah let's see this
one try use the knife not too much
because I don't want to get over at that
enthusiastic and end up dashing or
cutting stuff yeah this has the feel of
clothes something to wear during new
Doctor Who review other than cosplay
just just a thought love you happy
holidays
oh it's awesome so let's see what we got
there never be cruel or cowardly never
give up never give in ha ha
that's very cool weather oh ah we have a
variant now for
Wow because now it's got the so we got
the the 13th doctor stripe but also with
the TARDIS on it so not cosplay accurate
but I've got the cosplay accurate this
would just be for fun that's awesome
thank you all right I got one more this
is the big box and I am no clue what's
going on with this one um let's see on
top of being there we go
this is a long letter so um if I if I
keep parts of this in the video probably
just be highlights but we'll say dear
council of geeks first of all do you
have a preference for being addressed
some youtubers prefer their real name
some of their channel name some of no
preference either way I actually don't
really have a preference either way I
mean if you want a name you can go with
Nathaniel I first discover your channel
back during Doctor Who series 10 I've
been a fan ever since you're very
eloquent and charismatic your classic
dark and your classic whoo and Big
Finish reviews are highlights of my
months so much so that I became a patron
to participate in polls oh thank you you
along with other youtubers inspired me
to start up my own channel where I do
vlogs and reviews I find myself
fascinated you seem to do this
unscripted and you're so flawless I
don't know why anyone thinks I'm
flawless but okay I'm unscripted and I
stand by ramble and take long pause and
see I used to do that too it's practice
you got to realize I'm on my seventh
year of doing this I've just raw
practice you will get better after your
war master review I thought I'd send a
few more Big Finish spin-offs for you to
check out oh wow oh wow all of them our
series wants holy cow this letter went
on for so much longer than I wanted to
conclude by wishing you happy holidays
and I apologize for my scrawl your
handwriting is way better than mine
warmest regards Marcus or as you've
probably seen me in the comments in some
of your videos
sir Jett I sent know I have seen you and
oh wow okay so yeah we've got we have
Big Finish geez
oh my god it's boxset holy cow
so we've got J go and Lightfoot which
how I you know it might be next month
I'll kind of get to talk a little bit
about these characters oh my gosh
we've got countermeasures oh that's
sweet
formed by the for the countermeasures
group formed by the British government
to investigate new technologies the
unexplained and alien incursions oh
that's neat oh and the diary of River
Song
I mean this is one of those ones that
I've heard about and I didn't know when
I was gonna get around to it one of the
factors was being a boxset it's pricey
the box sets are not cheap which makes
the fact that you sent me three of these
all the more kind of insane to me and
awesome but yeah dire River Song oh wow
okay yeah I'm gonna well this will
definitely go up rather swiftly as an
option for the patreon supporters to
vote on for me to do I have a feeling
you might get up there but ya know this
is great cuz I've wanted to do a little
bit more of the spin-off stuff I've
actually gotten a hold of some Torchwood
stuff too again since I'm only doing one
big finish a month I can't promise how
quickly I'll get reviews out for these
but oh these are oh my gosh oh and I
also want to mention one other thing
because a few other people had sent me
letters that I gotten earlier so I want
to let you folks know that I did get
that Bronwen I did get that it was you
know Amy I I got it
and then the Robinsons that was a
Christmas card so yeah I've
it's funny I don't I don't highlight the
pl Box it's in the it's in the
description of all the videos but you
know I don't draw attention to us I
don't expect stuff to show up there so
when I went today and got this pile of
stuff
you folks are amazing I mean like you're
really awesome but I love just the fact
that you watch at all and you know that
some of you comments let me you support
me on patreon but you guys all of you
you're you're so nice yeah that's uh
feels good I hope you all have a
wonderful Christmas or just time of year
if you don't happen to celebrate that
particular holiday have a good New Year
I think that's a it's a good one to
shoot for regardless of anything else so
thank you that's I that's all I can end
on is thank you
usual ending spiel buttons links patreon
links to other stuff the peel box is
that on the description until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]